what's up everyone welcome to the video
today we're going to take a look at how
to get a 2022 Honda Odyssey started if
the key fob dies so like I said we'll be
demonstrating on a 22 Odyssey in this
video but it will be the same one
several different years
so I've taken the battery out of this
key fob to demonstrate
as you can see none of the buttons are
working if I try to start the vehicle as
I normally would
I'm going to get a message here telling
me to hold the remote near the start
button
so that's exactly what we're going to do
I'm going to take the remote and I'm
just going to touch the back of it to
the stop start button
and you hear it beep there and then you
see the stop start button glow solid and
now we can start it as normal
and then you'll just need to replace the
battery in your key fob as soon as you
can